it's the tick tock video everyone cannot
stop watching with over 50 million views
and a guest appearance from will ferrell
how can you go wrong this is ryan
reynolds and will ferrell doing the um
what's it called what challenge the what
challenge the
grace kelly challenge
we'll see you tomorrow we'll be back
here 12 15. take it away ryan bye
i could be brown i could be blue i could
be violet sky i could be hurtful i could
be purple i could be anything you like i
could be brown i could be blue i could
be vile at sky i could be hurtful i
could be purple i could be anything you
like i could be brown i could be blue i
could be vile at sky i could be hurtful
i could be purple i could be anything
you like i could be brown i could be
blue i could be vile as sky i could be
hurtful i could be purple i could be
anything you like i could be brown i
could be blue i could be vile with sky i
could be hurtful i could be purple i
could be anything you like i could be
brown i could be blue i could be violent